I've never cried eating food today we're
gonna eat the capsizing sauce which is
the spiciest sauce in Korea
I'm surprised you've never heard of this
yeah I've never heard of this before but
I know Korean food it's like generally
spicy so for Koreans to say this as a
spiciest in Korea that means it's super
spicy I had like a bad on this a couple
years back this thing's hot all right so
we're gonna eat this with a little bit
of challenge because why not
our challenge is to not make any noise
or sounds so you can't be like ah you
can't breathe we're eating this with
chicken wings right right how many wings
should we eat I think six is it a number
no I mean something's gonna come out of
our face if we're not making any sound
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh oh my god the moment after
diversified all my pores it's like
seriously all my pores open up I always
spicy and then I'm glad this wasn't a
competition no because you're probably
gonna go for pieces I know you will